$191,000
in the last 3 months taking only one
trade per day spending roughly 30
minutes on the charts and I am done for
the entire day. You can see here we had
four trading days in April so far. I
made $13,000
in March $54,000
in February $64,000
and in January $60,000.
And I have all the trades here
that I took. No complex analysis, no
multiple time frames, 10 time frames. I
see people looking into the monthly time
frames to define their bias. No, it's
not the case. This is so simple and
mechanical that even my grandma can
execute it. You don't need 2 years to
master it. Most people get it within 1
week. By the end of this video, you will
know exactly how to implement my
strategy and get results like this
without watching dozens of videos that
cherry picks trades, without learning
discretionary strategies that take years
to master, and if they are even
profitable at all. So, let's get
straight into it. First, let me show you
my setup. I trade the NQ only on the
5-minute time frame. I don't use other
time frames. I have here two indicators.
This is the Lux Algo Sessions indicator.
It's simply showing me the London AM
session and also the New York Stock
Exchange session. This session is where
I trade. And the other one is the Daxon
Trend indicator. This is my custom
indicator and it's simply showing me
higher time frame data into my 5-minute
chart. So, the white one is the 50
15-minutes EMA, the green one is the
30-minutes EMA, and the red one is the
1-hour EMA. Unlike other traders that I
see online teaching this, they are
checking 10 other time frames, switching
between them, trying to figure out what
the market is doing. I don't do any of
that. My EMAs are built from higher time
frame data, but displayed on my 5-minute
chart. This means that I see the full
picture, what institutions are seeing,
what the big players are watching, all
in one single chart without switching
any time frame. When they are stacked
and pointing down, the markets want to
go down. I'm only looking for shorts.
When they're stacked and pointing up,
the markets want to go up. I'm only
looking for long like you see here.
That's my entire bias under 10 seconds.
No weekly analysis, no drone levels on
six different time frame, just this.
This is the first part of my strategy.
Let me quickly clear this chart up and
give you the second part. I will also
write all the parts of my strategy right
here.
So now we defined our bias for the day.
The second part is I want to see a
counter trend. That means if we have a
bearish days like this, we need to see a
small upper trend like this.
Let's take this day as an example. So,
you can see clearly that the day is
bearish
and also
before the New York open, we had a
counter trend. That means we are clearly
going down, but yeah, here we have an
upper trend. You can call it a pullback,
you can call it a correction, you can
call it a counter trend. So, this is the
second part. I always wait for a counter
trend. So, let me quickly get rid of
this
and do the replay tool quickly
explain to you the next part. This is
the third and the most important part of
the strategy is I wait for fair value
gap to get inversed in the counter trend
in this
correction
after the markets are open. Now, we have
5 minutes left for the market is open.
The closest FVG that we can see that the
price didn't break. That means if we
have this fair value gap right here,
the price didn't broke this fair value
gap. So, this is the last fair value gap
that we have before the market is open.
So, let's quickly do this. You can see
that the first candle after market is
open broke this fair value gap. After
breaking the fair value gap, we go in
for a short position. We put the stop
loss above the candle that broke the
fair value gap and we target the closest
liquidity. You can see here we have a
liquidity. So, let's say we entered
right here. We have this liquidity right
here. We
we need always to target something
before we arrive to this liquidity
because sometimes price doesn't want to
touch this liquidity and reverse. Let's
see how this trade will do.
You can see clearly that we made 4% if
we risk 1%. This is from the 30th of
March. Let's go to the Yeah, you can see
here I was risking $2,000 and made 8.8k,
almost 9k. Like you saw, this was the
first example. Let's go to the previous
day and give you another example. Let's
do the bar replay right here before
market open. Let's get the strategy
right here. Now, we have also 5 minutes
until the market is open and we can see
clearly that we have a fair value gap
right here in the counter trend because
we are clearly bearish for the day like
you see here. All the EMAs are pointing
downwards. So, we have here a counter
trend, a pullback, a correction, you can
call it whatever you want. So, let's see
the first candle. We have a break of
this fair value gap. We enter, the stop
loss above this swing high. Let's check
for the last liquidity that we have to
the downside. As you can see, we have no
liquidity here. So, we will be targeting
a two RR for our TP. Let's see how this
trade will play.
You can see clearly that we did go
straight to the TP
of two
Rs. To This day was Friday, the 27th of
March. You can see here that I made a
little bit under 2% risking $2,000. And
let's go to the other previous day.
Let's bar right here.
So, like you see, this is the first
candle of the New York Stock Exchange in
this counter trend that you see here
right before market is open, we have
absolutely no fair value gap. So, we
wait. Let's play the candles. We can see
that we have a counter trend because we
are clearly moving to the downside. If
you can
uh check the EMAs. So, we are going up
for now.
We have
actually a fair value gap that forms
between these three candles. We have
this pullback going to the upside
between this first candle, the second
candle, and this third candle, we have a
clear fair value gap. So, we keep an eye
on it. Let's check what the market will
do.
You can see here clearly that we broke
this fair value gap. So, as always, we
go in right here.
The stop loss is above the candle that
broke the fair value gap. Let's look for
a liquidity to the left. We can see here
that we have this liquidity right here
in this area right here. So, this is a
liquidity that we have. Let's target it.
And like always, don't put your TP right
here.
Move it slightly before we get to this
liquidity. Let's see how it will play
out.
So, like I told you, never put the TP
right here at the liquidity because
sometimes price will simply will not get
to that liquidity. So, we have another
win right here. It's from the 26th of
March. You can see here that I made 3.2%
I believe or something like that.
Exactly like the trade you see here.
Now, let me show you the losses. I don't
want you to think that this strategy is
100% win or something.
It's 73% win rate. It prints to be
honest, but you will have losing days.
As you can see right here. So, let me
check the 25th of March.
It's that day. In the morning, I saw
that these EMAs are starting to point to
the upside. So, I waited for the New
York session to open. Like always, we
are above the EMAs and the EMAs are
pointing up. So, we always waiting for a
counter trend to the opposite side of
the trend. So, that means we want to see
a fair value gap forms in the opposite
trend of where the price is going and
wait for the price to inverse that fair
value gap. That means if we have a fair
value gap like this.
So, it's clearly
a bearish fair value gap. The price
broke this fair value gap right here
with this candle. I did go in here, put
my stop loss here,
and targeted this liquidity that we have
right here. I targeted this liquidity,
but I ended up losing this trade. This
is completely normal. This is a textbook
setup and I ended up losing this trade.
No problem. We move to the next day. And
as you can see, we had three winning
days after each other. Now, let me give
you the last example before we wrap this
video up. Like you see, we came up to
our setup before New York open and we
saw that the EMAs are stacked up. This
is a trade from the 1st of
April. And like I said, so the EMAs are
pointing up. The price is above the
EMAs. We will only be looking into
longs.
So, we have 5 minutes until market is
open. That means we will be looking into
a fair value gap inside a bearish
counter trend. Let's see what the price
will do. We can see here that New York
open started with a bullish candle and
we are waiting for a bearish fair value
gap to form.
So, we can see here that the start of
this candle and the end of this candle
formed a bearish counter trend. And we
can clearly see that we have here a
small fair value gap right here.
Now, we simply waiting for the price to
break this fair value gap. If you can
see here, we broke it. We entered a
long.
The stop loss is slightly here and let's
look for a liquidity. So, I can see no
liquidity to target. That's why I did
target a 2 hours.
And let's see what the price will do.
So, straight into TP. This is also a
textbook setup.
We have here an upper trend.
A mini downtrend, a fair value gap
formed into this counter trend. Price
broke right here.
This fair value gap and inverse that
fair value gap and we end up winning 2
hours. As you can see here, almost 2
hours risking $2,000.
So, let's rewind
this strategy from the get-go. First,
before doing anything, you need to
define your bias every single day before
New York is open. So, that's why I have
these EMAs who help me define my bias.
Second, I always wait for the counter
trend. So, if we have the price moving
like this, I always wait for these parts
and a fair value gap to be inversed in
these parts.
Then, I target either a previous
liquidity or 2 hours if I can't see a
clear liquidity that I will be
targeting. The stop loss goes always
above or under the swing high or the
swing low. And I trade only NQ on the
5-minute time frame. If you want to see
my next videos, make sure to subscribe
and like the video. Also, if you have
any questions, make sure to put your
comments below. Thank you so much for
watching my first video and let's meet
for new ones.